démocratiser l'investissement immobilier
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé fun dit
mot cette start up lancée en novembre
dernier par trois entrepreneurs est une
plateforme de financement participatif
spécialisé dans l'immobilier
l'immobilier est un investissement qui
n'était jusqu'à présent pas accessible
pour les particuliers pour monsieur tout
le monde et aujourd'hui grâce au
crowdfunding c'est possible vous pouvez
financer la construction la
réhabilitation d'actifs immobiliers dans
votre région
grâce à ce nouveau canal
d'investissement internet
pionnière en la matière fun demo répond
à la réglementation actuelle en étant
agréé auprès de l'autorité des marchés
financiers la plateforme propose déjà
cinq projets immobiliers sur son site
parmi eux le projet paris est à maurepas
avec la réalisation d'un bâtiment
d'activité de 5200 mètres carrés folle
demo a choisi la zone de meurent pas et
notamment la zone de paris ouest
de par son attractivité avec les grands
axes routiers de l'ouest parisien
l'autoroute a12 l'autoroute a13 et
nationale 10 et notamment également de
par son attractivité en termes de
projets qui ont déjà été réalisés sur la
zone de paris ouest
le projet de réalisation réhabilitation
d'immeubles d'activité et notamment de
rénovation d'immeubles existants
un site de crowfunding simple à utiliser
en quelques clics et à partir de 1000
euros le souscripteur investi dans le
projet immobilier auquel il croit une
nouvelle façon d'investir en court
circuitant les intermédiaires
traditionnels
nous sommes également une plateforme
indépendante puisque nous sommes
associés à aucun promoteur ni aucune
banque qui nous garantit une
indépendance totale dans l'analyse des
dossiers et dans la sélection des
projets que que mène la plateforme avec
un taux de rendement annuel de 8 à 12%
par projet la plateforme rencontre un
franc succès pour 2016 une quinzaine de
projets immobiliers sont déjà en
préparation